mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
the following problem appeared on the
2002-2003
british mathematical olympiad the
challenge is to write a complete proof
it is not sufficient to provide a
numerical answer alone
find all solutions and positive integers
a b and c to the equation a factorial
multiplied by b factorial is equal to a
factorial plus b factorial plus c
factorial
i thank nahin for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we will get started by noticing a
symmetry in this equation
what would happen if we transpose the
variables a and b
because multiplication and addition are
commutative we have an equivalent
equation
therefore if abc is a solution then we
know bac is also a solution
what this means is that if a solution
exists then a solution abc
with a less than or equal to b also
exists
without any loss of generality we can
suppose a is less than or equal to b
the proof will proceed in the following
four steps
first we'll prove that 3 is less than or
equal to a
then we'll show that b is less than c
then we'll prove a is equal to b
and finally we'll prove c is less than
or equal to a plus 2 and solve for the
numerical answer
let's get started by working out a few
cases
suppose a is either 0 or 1
then a factorial is equal to 1.
we substitute that into the original
equation and then simplify
this equation only has a solution if 0
is equal to 1 plus c factorial
but no solution exists for this equation
where c is a positive integer therefore
a cannot be equal to zero or one
we then consider the case a is equal to
two
this means a factorial is also equal to
two
we substitute that in and then we
simplify the equation
notice there is no factorial that's two
more than another factorial because the
factorial sequence goes in order 1 2 6
and so on
therefore this equation also has no
solutions for integers b and c
therefore a cannot be equal to two
this means a has to at least be equal to
three
then we suppose that a is less than or
equal to b so we could add that onto the
inequality
from here we're going to prove that b is
less than c
to do that we'll assume the opposite b
is greater than or equal to c and then
derive a contradiction
we can bound the sum a factorial plus b
factorial plus c factorial as follows
we've assumed that a is less than or
equal to b therefore a factorial will be
less than or equal to b factorial
then b factorial is equal to b factorial
we can then bounce c factorial because
we suppose that c is less than or equal
to b
therefore c factorial will be less than
or equal to b factorial
this sum will be equal to 3 multiplied
by b factorial so we have an upper bound
on the sum
but we can also derive a lower bound
this sum is equal to a factorial
multiplied by b factorial
we know that a is at least equal to 3
which means this is at least equal to 3
factorial multiplied by b factorial
which is equal to 6 multiplied by b
factorial
therefore we've shown the upper bound of
the sum
is actually lower than the lower bound
and that's a contradiction
therefore our assumption that b was
greater than or equal to c must have
been wrong and we've shown that b is
less than c
before we proceed to the next part of
the proof i'm going to go over a bit of
notation this notation means that m
divides n
it's equivalent to saying n is divisible
by m
it's equivalent to saying n is a
multiple of m
and it's equivalent to saying that m is
a factor or divisor of n
2 divides 4
3 divides 12 but 2 does not divide 5.
now let's show that a is equal to b to
do that we'll assume the opposite that a
is not equal to b
this means 3 is less than or equal to a
which is less than b which is less than
c
so we go to our original equation and
we'll divide both sides by a factorial
this simplifies to be the following
equation
notice the left hand side is b factorial
and the right hand side will be the sum
of three integers this is because b and
c are greater than a so b factorial over
a factorial is an integer and c
factorial over a factorial is an integer
now since b is at least equal to 3
we know that b factorial is an even
number that's because every factorial
above 3 factorial will be an even number
consequently the entire right hand side
which is the sum of integers has to be
an even number
now since 3 is less than or equal to a
is less than b is less than c
we know that b is at least equal to a
plus 1 and c is therefore at least equal
to a plus 2.
but then a plus 2 multiplied by a plus 1
must be an even factor of c factorial
over a factorial that's because the
product of any two consecutive numbers
is an even number
consequently 2 divides c factorial over
a factorial
now in order that the entire right hand
side be an even number we must have 1
plus b factorial over a factorial is an
even number but 1 is an odd number which
means we must have an odd number plus an
odd number so b factorial over a
factorial must be an odd number
now since b is greater than a this
implies that b is equal to a plus one
the reason is that if b was at least
equal to a plus two then it would have
an even factor of a plus two multiplied
by a plus one which is not possible
since b factorial over a factorial is an
odd number
so from here let's consider what happens
if b is equal to a plus one we'll
substitute that into our equation and
we'll simplify
we now consider the divisibility of this
equation by the factor a plus 1.
the left-hand side is a plus 1 factorial
naturally it has a factor of a plus one
the right hand side will be the sum of
three integers
naturally a plus one has a factor of a
plus one
now c factorial over a factorial will
also have a factor of a plus one because
c is at least equal to a plus two
therefore for the right hand side to be
divisible by a plus one we must have a
plus one divide one
but that means that a is equal to 0 and
that's a contradiction because we know
that a is at least equal to 3.
therefore our original assumption was
wrong
we cannot have a is not equal to b we
must have a is equal to b
we will then consider the next step
from here we want to prove that c is
less than or equal to a plus 2.
we'll again take our original equation
divide both sides by a factorial
we're going to substitute that a is
equal to b
and then we'll simplify this equation
we'll simplify it a little more and then
we'll subtract 2 from both sides
we'll again look at divisibility
since 3 is less than or equal to a
we know that a factorial is divisible by
3.
however we then know that a factorial
minus 2 is not divisible by 3. this is
because a factorial is a multiple of 3
and we're subtracting 2 from it
therefore 3 does not divide a factorial
minus 2 which means 3 cannot divide c
factorial over a factorial
now if c was greater than or equal to a
plus 3
then c factorial over a factorial would
have a factor of a plus 3 multiplied by
a plus 2 multiplied by 8 plus 1.
but 3 would divide this product because
one of three consecutive numbers must be
a multiple of three
therefore we must instead have c being
less than or equal to a plus two
so we only have two possibilities to
consider
either c is equal to a plus two or c is
equal to a plus one let's consider each
one in turn
suppose c was equal to a plus two
we'll substitute that into the equation
we'll then simplify this
and now we'll do a little bit of algebra
we'll multiply on the right hand side
and then we'll take all of the eight
terms to the left and put all the
constant terms on the right
now in this equation notice that every
single term on the left hand side of the
equation is divisible by a
this means that 4 has to be divisible by
a
but since a is greater than or equal to
3
the only way this is possible is if a is
equal to four
so let's substitute a is equal to four b
is equal to a which is equal to four and
then c is equal to a plus two so c is
equal to six
well if we substitute that into the
original equation we actually get
something that does not work 4 factorial
multiplied by 4 factorial is not equal
to 4 factorial plus 4 factorial plus 6
factorial therefore c is equal to a plus
2 it does not lead to a solution
so we instead need to consider the other
case that c is equal to a plus one
now in this case we'll substitute in and
then we'll simplify
we'll move the a terms on the left and
the constant terms on the right
now from this equation
a does divide a factorial minus a which
means that a would have to divide 3.
since a is greater than or equal to 3
this means that a is equal to 3.
so we now consider the possibility that
a is equal to 3 b is equal to 3 and c is
equal to a plus 1 which equals 4.
we substitute that in to the original
equation and ta-da we found the unique
solution
this is an incredible problem and the
proof is just so wonderful
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
as always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]